I've invested over $22,000
learning copywriting. I've written copy
every single day for the last four
years. I've sold over $220,000 of my own
digital products that I created,
marketed, and delivered. And I've built
an audience of over 10,000 copywriters
online and 5,000 on my email list. And
that's not even talking about the
clients that I've worked with.
Copywriting is what I do all day long.
What's going on? My name is Alan Drau
and in today we're going to be answering
your most burning deepest desire
questions about copywriting and the
email-based business that I have built
for myself. We've got some deep cuts in
here and some free gifts sprinkled along
the way. So, enjoy the ride. All right,
so I've got 35 questions. I've collected
these questions over the last few years
via email replies and Twitter and all
that stuff. I copied and pasted a bunch
of stuff into my notion document and
then I uploaded it to AI and said give
me the most frequently and commonly
asked questions out of all of these
questions. It has boiled it down to 35
questions for me. So I'm going to answer
all 35 of those for you. Let's dive
right in. Question number one, Allan,
can AI replace copywriters? I think AI
can replace copywriting
for some people, but I don't think it
will ever replace copywriters. It's
never going to get to the point where
it's self- autonomous in its ability to
do market research and product research
and find that product to market fit uh
in a unique fashion. Now, it's going to
be able to write copy and write bullets
and things like that, but it's always
going to need a mastermind behind it to
feed it the proper information so you
can get it to the goal that you want it
to get it to. So, will it replace
copywriters? No, not the good ones. Will
it replace people who don't know
anything about copywriting and they're
just prompting it? Yeah, absolutely.
It'll replace you. Yeah, absolutely
useless. You have to understand the
skill. Question number two, what's the
number one meta skill to learn in
copywriting? Oh, easy. Writing hooks.
Hooks is the number one meta skill to
learn in writing copy because it's 80%
of the viewership. David Oglevie
mentions that 80% of people who see your
ad will only read the headline and
nothing more. So, five times that's five
times the amount of people. And so if
you understand how to write hooks, you
will then have a significantly higher
likelihood that that person either reads
your email, your ad, your sales letter,
whatever it is. If you fail at the hook,
then you've wasted hours of writing
absolutely nothing, which is exactly why
I put together a uh free resource for
you called 101 super sticky hooks. I
left it in the link in the description
below. You can put your email in and
I'll send you 101 hook templates. This
is one of the most helpful resources
that you could ever have as a
copywriter. You dominate this and you
will get more attention, more clicks,
more sales for sure. Question number
three, how did you get your first
client? That's a really good question.
So, it's very different than how most
people think they should get their first
client. I actually got my first client
by writing on Twitter for a long time.
So, I was already writing copy for
myself, building my own products, doing
my own stuff. I never liked the idea of
client work because I had already spent
10 years in the marketing industry. Uh I
had a web design agency prior. I had a
logo agency. I had already had a lot of
experience working with clients. And so
when I started writing online, I already
had the plan to just write for myself. I
didn't want any other clients or
anything like that. Uh a friend of mine
who was a mutual connection between uh
the client that I did end up working
for, he reached out to me and was
curious, "Hey man, I know you're doing
this whole copywriting thing. I love
your emails. I love your ads, things
like that. Would you consider writing
for this guy? He runs an ecom brand,
blah blah blah, all this stuff. So, he
reached out. He connected us. We ended
up working together. I made a whole
bunch of money, like over 30 something
grand on that first client, which is the
only reason I agreed to it is because he
agreed to a super high commission. It
worked out really, really well. Uh, I
still don't do client work because it
still took an enormous amount of work to
do it. But overall, the way that I got
that first client was by writing online,
being present in people's inbox, by
sending a daily email, and eventually a
friend reached out to me through a
relationship and made the personal
connection. So, that is a great way to
have clients chase you instead of you
chasing them. Question number four is,
what's the number one copywriting book
you recommend? I hate this question.
Here's why I hate this question is
because everybody thinks there is some
silver bullet book that's like the end
all beall. Copywriting is like an art.
It's a it's a skill. It's a craft just
like anything else. Just like if you
were to learn to code or if you were to
learn to dance or if you were to learn
to play golf, it it all adds up
together. So there's no one book that's
like this was the end all beall book for
me. It was the process of reading
hundreds of copywriting books that
formed my mind into it. Now, there are
some great books that I would recommend.
And the first book that I would
genuinely recommend is the AdWee
copywriting handbook by Joe Sugarman.
But I wouldn't expect to read that book
and be like, "Okay, I've got it. Like
I've I've I've nailed it." No, I've
personally read over a hundred something
copywriting books. And every single time
I read a new copywriting book, my mind
is further formed into the art and craft
of copy. So, it's the process more than
it is the product. Question number five,
why did you niche down to email
copywriting instead of doing something
else like sales letters or ads or direct
mail? Uh, honestly, it was just a really
natural fit for me because I follow
people like Daniel Thrasell, Ben Settle,
Chris Orzowski, and I just love the way
that they got to tell or that they get
to tell stories every single day. And
so, you get to stay in this niche like
copywriting and marketing, but you get
to attack it from all kinds of different
angles because you can attach stories to
it. Whereas sales letter and ads are
more product focused and and they're
less consistent. So, how often are you
writing ads and and sales letters where
an email, you could write an email a
day, you could tell a story a day. And
so, it just had this more uh consistent,
fun storytelling, joyful process that I
can show up, write every single day, and
get better and better and better. So, it
was just a natural fit for me. Question
number six, what software do you use for
sending emails and why? Uh, I use
kit.com. Uh, I use it because it was the
si it's the simplest uh, email service
provider that I'd come across. I used
Beehive before. I didn't like it because
the way that they embedded all the crazy
designs and it was really hard to just
do a plain text email, which is what I
send. I used Ghost prior to that. Didn't
really like that because it was very
limited in sequences. Where Kit Kit kind
of has it all. You could do sequences,
landing pages, uh, plain text emails.
It's really simple. They have good
analytics. Um, I'm sure there's other
systems out there that are really,
really good. I've thought about
Berserker Mail, but I add images and
gifts to my email, so Berserker Mail is
kind of out for me. But yeah, overall, I
really like Kit. Question number seven,
can I be a copywriter if I'm not a
native English speaker? Uh, yes, but you
will have a hard time writing to native
English speakers. If you don't
understand English and you're trying to
write for the English market, the first
thing you should do is learn English.
And then from there, you know, you'll
learn copywriting. And it's not
something I recommend because
copywriting in itself is already very
hard to learn. And so now you're
learning two massive skills, right? Now
you have to learn English and then you
have to learn copyrightiting. But it's
not impossible, right? Like I didn't
know English till I was seven or eight
years old. My parents immigrated from
Romania. Romanian is actually my first
language. You know, obviously I wasn't
that old uh to overcome that difference,
you know, seven, eight years old. But
but over time, you know, if you master
uh the art of speaking English and then
you want to write copy in English, yeah,
that's totally fine. That's fantastic.
You could do it. It's just going to be
hard and it's going to take a long time.
Most people try and write copy first
while they're learning English. I would
not recommend that. I would recommend
learning English and then learning copy.
Question number eight, how long does it
take to make money from copywriting?
That all depends on you. Like for
example, one of the ways you can make
money today is let's say you you write
on Twitter, you launch a product on
Gumroad, it's a $2 product and it solves
a problem for someone. Let's say you put
together like a productivity notion
template or something that really solves
a problem. Dude, you could put out 101
15 tweets today uh to a killer Gumroad
$2 product that has great copy. You
could sell something today. So, you
could start making money today or you
could dillydally around 6 months reading
books thinking you're not good enough
and then you're trying to land a client
and that's going to take you another 3,
four months. There's there's all kinds
of different paths that people take that
either make it longer or shorter. My
preferred method is to write your own
stuff on social media, get those people
to an email list, write your own copy
via emails, and then sell your own
products via whatever platform, Gumroad
or anything like that. And it's all your
copy, your funnel the entire time. And
you can dictate the speed of how much
you sell, when you sell, uh, by your
ability to reach new people and write
great copy. Question number nine, what's
the best way to get feedback on my
copywriting without a mentor? Oh, easy.
Post on social media. Social media is a
great place to get instant feedback
because it is an instant feedback loop.
The minute you post something on social
media, you measure its worth by the
likes, the comments, the engagement, the
views, the retweets, things like that.
That's why I love Twitter so much is
because you could post something and if
it resonates, it's going to grow. You
know, if you typically get something
like five likes on a post, but then you
do this one post and it got 30 likes.
Well, that's that's a noise indicator
that says, "Whoa, something resonates
here." And so, that is a feedback loop.
You don't need a mentor. The whole world
is your mentor through the internet. And
then you get those people from social
media to an email list. And then you get
an even better measurement, which is
sales. When you get them to an email
list and you start selling them stuff,
you measure whether your copy is good by
how many sales you've got, right? Are
people clicking? Are they buying my
stuff? And if they're not, your copy is
probably not great or your offer is not
great or whatever it is. But social
media is the fastest way to get feedback
without having to hire a mentor.
Question number 10, how do I pick my
copywriting niche? I would say the
easiest way to pick a copywriting niche
is using a formula that I call the 4P
framework, which is passion, person,
problem, profit. Starting with passion,
what is the thing that you are most
passionate about? That's the easiest
place to start. For example, I really
like golf. I could probably write a golf
newsletter, sell golf stuff because I
enjoy it so much. And then the second
thing is, is profit? Is there profit in
it? I can Google it and realize that uh
golfers spend a lot of money. There's a
lot of golf products out there, billions
and billions and billions in that
market. So, easy to figure out. And then
problem, what problem do you solve for
those people? In person, who is the
person that you're trying to help? You
figure those four things out. And uh
it's a very clear way to get your niche.
Question number 11. Is copywriting worth
it in 2026?
Well, words are not going away and sales
is not going away. So yes, now a lot of
people throw out the whole AI thing.
Well, AI can do it, but remember AI
needs a master just like coding. I don't
know anything about code. And so if I go
into AI and I start telling it to code
stuff, it can code a whole bunch of
stuff. But if something goes wrong in
that code, I have no idea what went
wrong or how to fix it. Do I just prompt
the AI, hey, can you find this? And it
and it continues to go wrong because AI
is going to put out errors and things
like that. It's the same with copy. So
AI can write copy, but when it's wrong
or when it's not working and you have no
idea why it's not working, you are now
back to square one where you don't have
the fundamentals. don't understand the
art of persuasion and writing which are
still the two most insanely vital skills
in living. Persuasion and writing.
Everything is communicated through
writing. Even this video is written
form, right? Like these questions are
written. Everything that I'm saying is
written in persuasion. Getting people to
buy from you. Getting people to buy into
your ideas, your thoughts, your
products. All of that is copywriting. So
copywriting will never expire. It will
never go out of style. The art of
copywriting may change the way that it
impacts the industry, but learning the
skill has been around since Jesus. So
yeah, it's completely worth it. Question
number 12, how do I know what to charge
for my copywriting? If you are just
getting started out and you don't know
what to charge, I would one work for
free for a while so that way you can
build up your case studies and you can
build up a portfolio of experience that
you have so then you can further sell
later. So, like Alex Hormoszi says,
there is a time to earn and there is a
time to learn. When you're first getting
a couple clients, I would just be
learning. And then secondly, if you
don't know what to charge, I would take
a 100% commission deal. That's what I
did with my first client. And I made way
more than I would have charged a flat
fee. I may have been very timid and been
like, "Hey, I'll take, you know, like
3,000 bucks for all this work. Ended up
making 30 grand because of the
commission." So, I would say, "Hey, if I
beat X results by X amount, I want 10%."
Something like that. That I would start
there instead of flappy. I don't even
like flat fee and never get to flat fee.
You should always be doing commission
10% is a good standard. 10% of increased
attributable revenue on email or ads or
whatever. So that means whatever they're
already making, say they're making 100
grand a month on ads already. Say if I
make you 200 grand a month, I want 10%
of increased attributable revenue.
Meaning since you guys are already doing
100,000, I won't take commission off
that. But because I beat it, I want 10%
of the increased what I beat. So if you
make 200,000 and they were already
making a h 100,000, that means you made
them an extra 100,000. So you get 10% of
the extra because you clearly proved
yourself. I like structuring deals like
that. Question number 13, which is
better, long or short copy? Uh there is
no such thing as long or short copy
being better or worse. It's only boring
or exciting copy. So, if it's 20 pages
worth of copy, but it's entertaining as
hell the entire time and somebody cannot
stop reading it and it's very
persuasive, then 20 pages is perfect.
But if it's three pages and it's boring,
then three pages is too long. It's never
a matter of long or short. I mean, think
about it. JK Rowling wrote seven novels
for Harry Potter. A million words,
right? That is an enormous amount of
book, right? If the book had been
boring, nobody would buy it. But because
the book wasn't boring, everybody in
their mother bought it and it's the
number one fiction selling book in the
world. So think more like a fiction
author and less like some fancy
copyriter that sells stuff. You need to
be entertaining people while persuading
them. So long, short, doesn't matter.
Boring or exciting, that's what matters.
Question number 14, how do I do market
research? Well, there's a lot of ways to
do it. You can spend time in your
market. You can talk to those people.
You can research Reddit. You can go on
YouTube and scrape a bunch of comments.
There's a bunch of ways, but I did
create ChatGpt AI prompts that it'll do
it for you using ChatGpt or Gemini's
deep research functionality. So, it's a
fiveprong process, super detailed. I put
it a link in the description below. It
takes like 15 minutes and it does all
your market research for you. Pains,
problems, hopes, desires, it scrapes
Reddit, YouTube, all those websites, and
it formats it really beautifully for
you. You can grab that. It's free uh
market research prompts down below.
Fastest and easiest way. That's how I do
all my market research nowadays.
Question number 15. What are some
copywriting formulas you swear by? I
used to swear by things like ADA and PAS
and BAB, and I still use those, but I
don't really swear by any particular
formula anymore. I'm more focused on the
storytelling and the hook. If I get the
hook right and the story is excellent,
everything else really falls into place.
So, I don't really try and structure it
with a particular copywriting formula.
I'm just looking for an incredible hook,
which again, I left a link in the
description below if you want the 101
hook templates. And I'm looking for an
incredible story to inject after that
hook. Those are the only really two
things I swear by in copy is hook and
story. Number 16. What software do you
use for writing? I write everything uh
on my computer in notion, but I also
write a lot of my copy on my typewriter.
I have this freerite traveler
typewriter, which isn't really a
software or an app. It's literally a
typewriter and then when I'm done
writing I hit send and it goes into my
email inbox and then I move that over to
notion. I like notion because it has a
calendar functionality and uh and so you
can schedule stuff out inside of notion
so I can visually see my daily emails,
my social media posts, my YouTube
videos, things like that. So I just I
like notion for the functionality.
Question number 17, what is the best
place to connect with copywriters? The
easiest place to connect with
copywriters is on Twitter. I really like
Twitter because there's a ton of great
people there and uh and if you're really
kind and you post great content, you'll
meet people that you do not deserve to
be in a room with. I have a bias towards
it because I met a ton of people on
Twitter and I still have those
relationships to this today. So, that's
the easiest and free spot to to do it.
The next best place is a community that
I built, the Copy Creator Club. So,
right now we have over 60 highly
talented copywriters and they're
building their own email-based business
just like me. No client work. Uh great
copywriters. It's 50 bucks a month. It
is a paid uh community which I actually
think are a lot better than a lot of the
free Facebook group communities cuz uh
you know it's just a bunch of or or
Reddit. I don't like Reddit or any of
those things because it's just a bunch
of newbies asking the same things over
and over and they don't really know
anything about copyrightiting and so
they parrot each other and it's just bad
information and bad advice all around.
If you're looking just to make friends
and things like that, I would stick to
Twitter, find cool people, meet them in
the direct messages, get to know them
that way. or if you're looking to bounce
ideas and really collaborate with other
copywriters, I would look for a group
like mine, Copy Creator Club, link in
the description below if you want to
click it and check it out. And that way,
you know that you're getting really
quality people that are obviously paying
for a service cuz they're talented and
they're really good at what they're
doing. Question number 18, where can I
go to study great copywriting? Uh, two
things that I would recommend is find
great copywriters that you love to read
and join their email list. Like for me,
I love to read Ben Settle and Daniel
Thrasell, Chris Orzacowski, Laura
Belgray as far as copywriters go and
they all send very consistent emails. So
I subscribe to their email list to read
their great copy every single day. And
being an email copywriter, I want to
read more email copy. Another place is a
website called swiped.co. I'll leave it
in the description below for you to
check it out. So swipe.co Co has just
collected a lot of like sales letters
and ads that have been really high
performing and you can search on
swipe.co like Gary Benvga and John
Carlton and great copywriters. Their ads
will pop up. You can print them. You can
read them online and that's just great
copy. It's a free place to get a bunch
of great copy. Question number 19. What
are the best niches to write copy for?
Uh the big three are health, wealth, and
relationships. Anything that makes
somebody healthier, uh, makes them more
money or makes their relationships
better with other people like networking
and things like that. Those are always
going to be the big three. I obviously
write copy for a copywriter. So, I would
be considered in the wealth category.
You can write in other niches like again
I mentioned golf earlier. Doesn't really
bode well in those three categories
where maybe relationships, but golf is a
sport and it's still a very highly
profitable niche. But the three that
will always stand the test of time is
health, wealth, and relationships.
Question number 20. What do you
personally love to read and study
copywriting from? I personally love to
read emails. I like to read emails again
from my favorite email copywriters. Ben
Settle, uh, Daniel Thrussell, Laura Belg
Gray, Chris Orzikowski. Those are kind
of my favorite copywriters that I love
to read on a daily basis. I also love to
read fiction novels way outside of the
copywriting world. And I love to read
newsletters outside of the copywriting
world because I want to have multiple
perspectives to my writing angles. So
fiction novels for the storytelling
aspect. Uh I like reading emails from
copywriters so I can see how they write
in the industry that I am also writing
in. And then I like reading newsletters
outside of the copywriting world
entirely so I can see what's interesting
about their emails. So getting a more
broad-based and then using it to develop
my own style and tone. Question number
21. How do you flesh out a big idea when
you write? Basically, whenever I'm
trying to write uh an email or sales
letter or anything, I'm looking for the
one thing I really want to communicate
and I align that with the one problem
that my audience has and then I try and
find some sort of twist or angle to
that. So, so one thing I want to
communicate to the one problem my
audience has with a twist. Okay. So, for
example, I may write an article about
how to write $1,000 emails. Okay? My
audience has the problem of writing
emails that don't make any money, right?
Writing emails that don't get sales. So,
I may write an email and my big idea is
how to write a $1,000 email. That's the
big idea. Okay? That's that's
interesting. It's intriguing. It solves
a problem. But then I add a twist. Okay?
How to write a $1,000 email in 10
minutes. Now, I took a big idea and and
I niched it down, but it's significantly
more interesting because I added the
twist. So, it's something that I know
that has solved a problem for this very
specific person and I twisted it so that
way it makes it significantly more
intriguing and interesting. That twist
is kind of the magic bullet, but it has
to still solve a problem for your
audience. That's kind of how I flesh it
out. Question number 22. What is a good
daily practice routine for copywriting?
I would say anything that gets you to
write a,000 words a day. If you can
write 1,000 words a day, that solves
99.9% of your problems. Like for me, for
example, I'll wake up at about 6:00 a.m.
I will make an espresso or an Americano,
something like that. I'll do my stretch,
get some water, and I just kind of bum
around till about 6:30ish, right? Let my
let my soul catch up with my body, and
then I'll go sit down and I'll write for
about 45 minutes to an hour, right?
That'll get my thousand words, maybe a
little bit more, and I get that knocked
out for the day. Most of the time, I
will write significantly more than that,
right? I'll come back a couple hours
later, I'm working on other projects.
I'll write another thousand words,
another thousand words. But at the end
of the day, if you write your thousand
words clean somewhere, right? You find a
place that you love to write. I love to
write in my office. You find the vibes
that you want to write with. Like I like
I like wearing uh lowfi beat headphones
where I big wear these big overear
headphones listening to lowfi beats and
uh and I'll turn some candles on. I got
my espresso so I create this vibe and I
just enjoy it to write my thousand
words. So find a place, a time, an
experience for you to enjoy writing a
thousand words. Knock out your thousand
and that's going to be the best
copywriting routine you could ever have.
Question number 23. How do I know if my
copy is good or not? Well, it either
sells or it doesn't. Right? Copywriting
is essentially sales in words. So it
either sales, which you know, if you're
sending emails out, right, sales is
going to be your number one metric. But
if you're writing copy for things like
social media and you're trying to
persuade them, what are you trying to
persuade them to do? To subscribe to
your email list, well, how many people
saw your post versus how many people
joined your email list, right? Those are
the metrics of what are you trying to
measure of success for your copy? Did
you do that successfully or not? That's
it. and sales is usually the number one
metric. Number 24, who are the best
copywriters to study? Uh, one, me.
Definitely study my emails. Join my
email list at all dragood.com. I write a
daily email and I've been doing this for
a long time and you will love my emails.
But aside from me, it depends on what
you're writing. Like if you're writing
sales letters, right, you're going to be
trying to study people like Clayton
Makepiece, Gary Benga, John Carlton. If
you're studying emails, you're going to
be spending more time studying people
like myself, Daniel Thras, Ben Settle,
Chris Orsacowski. If you're doing uh you
know like cold traffic ads or anything
like that, you may be studying people
like Alex Ramoszi or Frank Kern or Dan
Kennedy. So it depends on the medium
that you are trying to learn and then
studying those guys. I like studying all
of them because you can kind of take
bits of these multiple different avenues
and and form your own voice. But but
yeah, those are going to be your your
go-to legends. Question number 25. What
is the fastest way to make 10K per month
copywriting? Well, I would dare say that
the fastest way to make $10,000 per
month is not always the best way to make
$10,000 per month. The fastest way to
make $10,000 per month is by getting
four clients to pay you $2,500 a month.
You can do this in a lot of industries
like ecom, info products, influencer
marketing, things like that through
email copywriting, sales letters,
whatever it is. $2,500 is a great rate.
It's affordable enough for most
companies making a million bucks or
more, which opens up the options for you
to reach out to a lot of people. You can
warm network. So, you could probably get
that in 3 to 6 months with some really
intense hustle. But I would dare venture
to say that you should actually invest
in your own business through either a
paid newsletter or a paid community.
Like for myself, I have a paid community
on school. We have about 60 members a
month right now. That's about three
grand per month. We've done that in the
last couple months. I'm projected to hit
about 200 members by the end of the
year. 200 members paying me $50 a month
is 10 grand per month. I would much
rather have that business than the
client business. There's just much more
headache and time involved in the client
business for a lot of different reasons.
And so I would say build the $10,000 per
month business that you enjoy as opposed
to the one that gets you there the
fastest. Question number 26. Is there a
difference between writing on social
media and copywriting? Yes, there's been
this dichotomy between like content
writing and copywriting where content
writing on social media is definitely
meant more to like educate and
entertain, but over the years they've
kind of merged to actually be the same
thing because copywriting has went from
more like hard pushy sales to more
education to entertainment. And social
media has gone from more like
entertainment education to more hard
pushy sales. So the worlds have kind of
merged into this like infotainment vibe
that Ben Settle constantly talks about
and and truly social media has become
like you're honestly trying to persuade
them to do something whether it's buy
your book or join your email list or
click the link below or whatever, right?
You are trying to be persuasive which is
ding ding ding copywriting. And so it
really all kind of is the same thing
nowadays. And so the skills that you
learn in copywriting can be translated
into social media, emails, sales,
whatever you want to write. Question
number 27. How do I find my writing
voice? Well, you don't really find it,
you discover it. Where like implying
that you find it is like one day you're
just like, ah, that's what I sound like.
And that's not true at all. Really, the
way I have found my writing voice is
that every day for the last four years,
I've woken up, had some espresso, and
wrote at least a thousand words of copy.
And it has been a brutal journey because
I don't actually feel like I understood
my writing voice. And I tried all kinds
of different things until, you know,
about a year ago, so 3 years into my
journey when I started feeling like, oh
yeah, I think this is what I sound like.
And even now, I'm still adapting and
changing. And that all comes from what
you consume. For me, I mentioned I read
Ben Settle and Daniel Thros. I read a
lot of fiction novels. I read other
authors, non-fiction authors like Morgan
Hel and John Mark Comr and Ryan
Holidayiday. And all of that plays into
my writing voice. I take what I like
from those guys. I take what I don't
like and I push those kinds of things
away and and it develops into this own
style and you adapt it through writing.
If you consume a lot but you don't
write, you never develop your voice. If
you write a lot but you don't consume,
you never find different angles to play
with. And so you kind of need both. You
need a consumption habit and and a
concentration habit of writing daily and
then eventually you start sounding like
you. Question number 28. When do you
typically write your copy and how much
do you write in a day? I've answered
this a couple times. I typically write
my copy at about 6:30 in the morning
because my kids are asleep, my wife's
asleep, and it's quiet. Um, and I write
about at least 1,000 words a day.
Usually, it's 2 to 3,000 because, you
know, I'll get later in the day and I'll
make more stuff for my school community.
I'll write YouTube scripts. I'll write
social media content. I'll write emails.
I'll be working on a sales letter, a new
product. There's just a lot of things
I'm constantly writing. And so, if I get
my thousand in, awesome. But it's
typically 2 to 3,000. Question number
29. How do I overcome writer's block? I
actually don't believe there's a such
thing as writer's block. I think it's
actually boring block. So, if you are
writing about something you either don't
care about or you don't know anything
about, then you're not going to know
what to write. So, like for example, if
a client came up to me, which I don't do
client work, but if a client came up to
me and was like, "Hey, I have a roofing
company and I'll and I'll pay you to
write for my roofing company." I'm going
to have a really hard time writing for
that roofing company because one, I
don't care about roofing companies and
two, I don't know anything about roofing
companies. So, I'm going to have to do
all of this research. I'm going to drag
myself through it and I have no passion
for it. And so, yeah, I'm going to be
staring at a blank page cuz I have no
idea what to say. And so, it takes an
enormous amount of work to overcome that
because I'm bored by the subject. But if
you asked me and you were like, "Hey,
can you write a sales letter on golf or
can you write something about taekwond
do or karate? Can you write something
about boxing or guitar or copywriting?"
I, you know, you just named 10 things
that I love and I'd be like, "Yeah, no
problem." and right and I could talk
about those things all day long. And so
writer's block only exists if you're
writing about something you don't care
about. The best way to beat that is to
build your own business, sell your own
stuff in a niche that you love and you
love to write about. Question number 30.
What do I do if my client doesn't like
the copy that I wrote? That's a really,
really good question. My favorite way to
deal with this with clients is to take
the conversation from like my copy
versus their preferences or anything
like that. What you're doing there is
you're actually anchoring the copy on
either of yours opinions and you want to
get it out of the opinion conversation
and you want to raise the floor to a
data conversation. So it's not my
opinion versus your opinion. It's what
does the data say? Because ultimately
you are not necessarily the end result
of your copy and neither is the client.
the market that you are selling to for
the client is the end result. They will
tell you whether the copy is awesome or
not. So if your client comes back and
says, "Oh, this is too bold or it's not
bold enough or whatever," you may come
back and be like, "Hey, let's do this.
Let's AB test five different layers of
copy, right? Let's try a bold one, a not
bold one, this angle, that angle, and
let's see what the market says. And when
the data comes back to tell us, you
know, whether this one got sales or that
one got sales, let's just go with the
one that gets the most sales." So that
way it's not you against your client,
but it's both of you for the market.
You're moving the conversation from
opinion to data. That way you're not
defensive. You're also not attacking
them and both of you are moving towards
a similar direction of a goal. Question
number 31. Why do you hate client work
so much? Lol. Uh, I don't nec No, I do.
I don't like it. The reason I don't like
client work is because it is no
different than a 9-to-five industry
where you're still trading time for a
paycheck, right? I have to put x amount
of time in and give you x amount of
deliverables for x amount of money. Not
only that, but clients expect phone
calls and data reports and they want you
to bend over backwards for them. And
even if you have the best clients in the
world, you are still doing an enormous
amount of work more on their time frame
and Google calendar and whatever it is
where as opposed to if you built your
own business, your own email list and
you sold your own stuff. You get to pick
your own schedule. You get to make your
own products. You get to adjust your own
copy. They're not giving you revisions.
You get to create your own offers. You
get to change those offers last minute
or don't change them at all if you don't
want to. You get to have full autonomy
and control of when you work, how you
work, when you don't work. And that
level of leverage and freedom just does
not exist in client work. And in the
time that we live in with the internet
and email and digital atmosphere and all
the good things that you have at your
fingertips, it just makes no sense to me
to put yourself at the mercy of four to
five clients a month dictating what's
good and what isn't good. Get on my
schedule, meet with my people, sell
these offers. Like, it just it doesn't
make any sense when you have the
opportunity to do your own thing.
Question number 32. You spent $22,000
learning copy. Is it worth having spent
that amount of money on copywriting? I
mean, are you getting something really
new every time you buy a book or a
course? Is it worth it? Well, I've sold
10 times the amount just for myself, not
including any client work. So, it's
already made its return on the
investment 10x for me. And there's very
few things in life that will give you a
10x return. So, yeah, that in itself is
already worth it. And two, do I learn
anything new every time I buy a book or
a course? I'm not looking to learn
something new every time I buy a book or
course. I'm trying to understand the
fundamentals at a deeper level that I've
not seen it before. which is different
because if I spent $22,000 on all these
books and courses and things that I
bought, I'm reading them from the
perspective of this guy Dan Kennedy and
then Ben Settle and then Daniel
Thrussell and then Brian Curts and then
Clayton Makepiece and I'm getting their
journeys, their angles, their storylines
on how they applied the fundamentals in
different ways. And those things mold
your mind over time and that investment
buys your skin into the game to output
better. It's not a matter of can I just
learn everything with a $22 copywriting
book and call it a day. Sure. Yeah. Go
buy the AD week copywriting handbook by
Joe Sugarman. You'll learn 80% of the
copywriting skills that you need. You
read that book 10 times and you're good
to go. But to me, that's not mastery.
That's like the good enough crap that
people look for on Twitter. I'm looking
for mastery. I'm looking to explore
every nook and cranny about the details,
right? The devil's in the details. And
I'm looking to get as layered deep into
everything about this industry so that I
can be in that upper 1% echelon. And you
don't get that by reading one book by
one person. It just doesn't exist. Too
many people are looking for shortcuts to
get that good enough. I'm looking for
mastery. And that is a shortcut question
that I think you're just you're you're
looking at it the wrong way. Question
number 33. Do you still believe that
cold outreaching prospects is still the
way to go in 2026? if not what is uh
that is assuming that I thought that
cold outreach was the way to go before
2026 and it is not. I've never once
thought that cold outreaching people was
the best way to get clients or customers
or whatever it is. Uh and no, I don't
think it is the way in 2026. I still
think that the best way has always been
the same way since Jesus was born and
that is through your warm network and
relationships. The way that I did that
was by writing content on Twitter,
building a relationship with a bunch of
people on Twitter and then getting to
know those people through comments and
DMs and emails and things like that.
That is how every single person has ever
reached out to me to be a customer or to
be a client of mine is they've known me
through organic conversations. I don't
think that reaching out to somebody and
being like, "Hey bro, your funnel sucks
and here are five ways to fix it. My
company will do it for you for free for
30 days." the like that stuff is so
annoying and nobody likes it. And the
only people that actually benefit from
it are the gurus who are putting
together cold outreach courses and
templates to sell you. They make
significantly more money than the people
actually trying cold outreach, which
should tell you something about cold
outreach. So, the stupid slow hard way
of building relationships is and always
will be the number one way to get
customers and clients. Question number
34. Who's the client that you wish
called you again because it was so great
to work with them? Again, I don't really
love client work or wish to work with
any of my clients ever again. But I do
have one guy that I wouldn't even
consider a client. He's just a really
good friend of mine. I write an email a
week for him in exchange for an enormous
amount of steak. He has a farm. I sell
his farm goods with the emails and he
sends me a butt ton of steak in return.
I eat all the steak. It's good protein.
Makes my body strong. It's my favorite
exchange ever. He lets me write whenever
I want. He never checks my emails. He
never checks in on me. He never asks me
to change anything. He doesn't even
remember that the emails go out except
when he gets them. He thinks they're
hilarious. He sends me a text, says,
"Thanks so much." And then he mails me a
bunch of steak. That's the best guy I
could ever write for. He's a good
friend. So, we'll be working with him
for a long time. All right. And the last
question, question number 35. How do I
go viral on Twitter? Easy. Write better
hooks. Hooks is the number one way to go
viral anywhere. It could be YouTube, Tik
Tok, Twitter. It's the first three
seconds of your video or it's the first
sentence of your copy on Twitter. And
the best way to write really, really
good hooks is to study really great
hooks, which I've already put a link in
the description below for 101 super
sticky hook templates. You could take
those. So that's your next 101 tweets.
If you tweeted once a day for the next
100 days, and then you repeated it three
times, you now have a year's worth of
content just off that one resource. So
you can click the link below, study
those hooks, write some stuff for
Twitter. That is the number one way to
go viral. Well, that wraps us up. I
appreciate you. Thank you so much for
watching. I hope you enjoyed this. And
if you did, go ahead and subscribe to
the channel and like the video. It tells
me that you want more content like this,
which by the way, I've got some insane
deep dive copywriting tutorials
dropping. I'm talking really indepth
masterclass course level stuff coming to
the channel in 2026. So, I dare say you
would be a fool not to hit that
subscribe button right now. Now, it
takes you 3 seconds and it means a lot
to me. So, go ahead and do that for me.